Let's discuss this solution for our Iron
Law quiz. The execution time is number of
instructions in the program 3 times 10 to
the 9th which is 3 billion, times cycles
per instruction, in this case times 2 and times the clock cycle time. Now note
that we have here three gigahertz which is
how many clock cycles we have per second.
What we need is how many seconds per clock cycle. So the clock cycle
time is 1 over 3 billion. Make sure you remember that this should here be clock
cycle time. Usually we express processor clocks
in terms of clock frequency, which is 1
over time. And conveniently, these two can be crossed out and we get 2 seconds.
So the execution time is 2 seconds.